als erstes eine fortsetzung also nicht
themen thematisch aber ich hatte halt
bei auf meinem ersten album von den song
gute frauen lieben schlechte männer
chronologisch chronologisch hätte der
eigentlich nach gutem einer dem
schlechte frauen kommen müssen gute
männer lieben schlechte frauen ich habe
jetzt diesen satz gesagt ist meine
eigene geschichte die ich das
verarbeitet habe so meine abschiedsbrief
an meiner ex freundin für die ich im
laufe meiner karriere glaube ich schon
zwei drei songs gemacht habe und ja da
habe ich halt das fazit daraus gezogen
gut meiner liebe schlechte frauen
nachdem gute männer die schlechte frauen
geliebt haben werden sie schlechte
männer finden eine gute frau die gute
frau fängt an den schlechten mann zu
lieben wird hinterher weil sie den
falschen geliebt hat zu einer schlechten
frau und trifft wieder einen guten mann
und so befinden wir uns in einen ewigen
teufelskreis also dafür ist dass ein
teufelskreis ist das wirklich ein tages
reise führt ihn ein attribut das mit
seiner freundin zusammen zwei jahre zwei
jahre
und wann ist sie zur schlechten v
gewonnen keine ahnung ich glaube
mittlerweile zurückblicken kann sein
dass die ganze zeit über die schlechte
vor gewesen aber jetzt jetzt bin ich da
schlechte man in sehr viele gute frauen
zum opfer gefallen sind aber jetzt
gerade finde ich auch wieder meine hohe
und alles ist schön und gut
das ist halt ist halt so passiert
passiert jedem diese erfahrung sammelt
glaube ich jeder mann und jede frau aber
es gibt auch ausnahmefälle ganz ehrlich
es gibt menschen die treffen sich lieben
sich beiden zusammen heiraten kriegen
ganz viele kinder und gibt es auch aber
selten weiter
aber warum ist das bei der der fall
gewesen warum warum es bei dir so
gelaufen
achtet bei frauen vielleicht auch falsch
auf die falsche eigenschaften
ich weiß nicht ob es liegt daran dass
wir sind ein bisschen
irgendwie sind wir sehr intensiv was
liebe angeht und die meisten kopf
geschickten menschen in der liebe also
männer die helfer sind doch meistens
immer kann irgendwie und das kommt
glaube ich davor dass irgendwie sehr
temperamentvoll sind und wesentlich eine
gewisse situationen vielleicht nicht
cool reagieren können und uns selber in
eine gewisse abseitsposition fordern mit
diesem verhalten und dann starke
selbstbewusste frau weiß man wie diesen
aggressiven [ __ ] das leben zur hölle
macht und man in bremen wir durch
passiert oft aber wir kommen bei diesen
frauen
wir waren verliebst du nicht weißt was
ist die situation wo vermutet wo du
wirst du dann schwach oder ist es eine
situation wo du zeigst dich wir jetzt
mal zeigen wie viel testosteron ich in
meinem körper ein was nicht dass in
sachen die man halt passieren rechnet
meine person sondern ist halt passiert
aber bei mir ist es auch nicht oft in
einem passieren dass einmal passiert und
wenn es jetzt noch mal passieren würde
dann ist es deswegen weiß ich
mittlerweile erwachsen bin und weiß auf
welche werte ich war einer frau zu
achten haben welche centers ehrlichkeit
treue bodenständigkeit dass sie selber
nicht auf zu viel falsche werte achten
und eine frau finde ich die für die
zukunft geeignet sein sollte muss eine
soldaten sind die soldaten eine
kämpferin
er muss muss muss mit die die schönen
zeiten genießen können somit die richtig
scheiße griechen können wenn ich scheiße
am dampfen ist ja und das findet man
heutzutage nicht mehr sehr oft aber aber
wie findet man so gottweis keine ahnung
also ich wünsche jedem dass er
irgendwann immer in seinem leben
automatisch an diesem punkt kommt damit
jeder den genuss verspüren kann wie es
ist irgendwann mal in einem gewissen
alter heiraten zu können kinder zu
kriegen und die wahren hüter des lebens
kennen zur hast du deine idee wie du in
zukunft keine schlechte frau in
anführungszeichen kennenlernen wirst
einfach noch oder wer bist du glaubst du
dass du den teufelskreis nicht
entweichen kann
ruhiger werden wie gesagt sich selber
ein bisschen ausbremsen nicht so viel
vom hotel zu hotel springen und das
rapper dasein ausnutzen und zur ruhe
kommen und dann wird man auch wieder
ruhige frauen kennen ist das
verführerische im geschäft von hotels
over time edt spray ich bin zu 100
prozent heterosexuelle ich sagen es gibt
menschen die leben nicht sehr viel wert
auf sexualität ich habe sehr lange zeit
sehr viel wert darauf gelegt jetzt auf
jeden fall wieder ein bisschen ein
bisschen zurückgetreten ist das gut für
musik was hat eigentlich nicht viel mit
der musik zu tun gehabt
von wegen frohes beides inspiriert das
reale leben inspiriert aber auch wenn du
am durchdrehen bis zum action machst
dann inspiriert dass auch das findet
sich alles in den text wieder das müssen
auch mal die konsumenten da draußen mal
begreifen ein künstler ist kein roboter
er ein künstler ist auch ein mensch und
gerade ein rapper berichtete aus seinem
leben und einleben kann sich jedes jahr
verändern
herz was weiß ich vielleicht passiert
morgen ein schlag in meinem leben dass
ich total wieder dornbirn und wieder
voll die demo gemacht vielleicht
passiert morgen eben ein jackpot dass
ich der diesen exzessen selber wieder
voll verfallen und alles mit füßen trete
was ich letztes jahr noch gepredigt habe
und auf einmal auf partys und sprecher
und champagnerflaschen könnte mein leben
entwickelt sich ich entwickle mich als
mensch und so entwickelt sich auch die
musik das müssen die leute mal ein
bisschen begreifen dass wir auch nur
menschen sind
das kann aber so zurzeit probiere ich
einer linie treu zu bleiben
auch mein leben gerade treu bleibt und
nach vorne bewegt und wir gucken einfach
hessische zukunft entwickelt dann
wünsche ihr dass das so diese richtung
auch weiterhin